hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to
another episode of the game engine
series the last time we
basically implemented our camera
component ui check out that video if you
haven't already and today we're going to
be just progressing through our
checklist you know
having a roadmap is so nice having like
some kind of
you know goal that you've planned for
and you've actually like developed a
strategy to get there
is really important i actually made a
video recently about the importance of
like long-term planning and road mapping
and all that stuff i'll link it up there
in case you're interested
but uh i honestly it's amazing just
being able to sit down and
everything's just here like i know
exactly what i'm working on it's so easy
and without further ado let's actually
start doing some of that work
so in the roadmap which anyone can
access hazel engine.com
roadmap we have this hazelnut ui
mvp that we're working towards next up
is apparently the tag component ui
and the sprite renderer component ui so
we did the camera component last time
and now we're doing these two in the
next episode we'll probably
go to transform component now these
obviously don't need an episode each in
fact i'm pretty sure this is mostly done
we're about to investigate that
but this is uh yeah this sprite
rendering burner ui needs to be done
today and then this stuff we can look at
next time so
if we just quickly have a run of this
hazel engine let's take a look at what
we've got here and what we actually need
to do
so um we need to so
what we've got at the moment is this
weird clip space entity
which as far as i'm concerned is uh
just um a camera right so if we enable
it you can see it moves the camera
because if we set this camera to primary
i mean
so i don't know why it's called this
clip space entity it's actually like
some kind of camera b
or something like that it's funny how
that moves um because the wa sd keys
move the camera and i guess i pressed a
couple times here
um so uh that's a camera cool we've got
the camera entity which is another
camera obviously that's currently the
primary camera if we disable it then we
have no cameras so nothing renders
we've got the red square which is what
we see here and we've actually got the
green square as well that's on the same
position so if we move that out of the
way
you can see it's over here now at the
moment if we actually
do look at this you can see that in the
settings panel over here we actually
have green square and then the square
color
so this this just happens to be bound to
this particular square
so if i click on this i can cycle
through all the colors you can see and
it's modifying
this green square let's set it back to
green so we're not confused so
obviously this is not something we want
to manually bind to this i'm gui
settings panel that was just temporary
we want to actually be able to control
like the color and maybe potentially
other properties of the sprite renderer
inside this
properties panel because the sprite
renderer is actually a component
that is on our well green square in this
case or really on
any entity now this becomes a bit a bit
more i guess it's a bit deeper than that
because
if you think about how a sprite renderer
component usually works
it's usually tied to a material so good
you have a sprite
renderer right you have an entity and
you want to render a sprite in place of
that entity
you know with the entities transform and
all of that but what kind of sprite is
it does it have a texture
does it have a color is it what color is
it what shader should i be using for
this
all of those questions basically point
to hey man you need a material
right now we don't have a material
system at the moment so
in the future when we have a sprite
rendered component we should have it
taken a material that way we can make a
you know just a weird reflective sprite
if we want to maybe i mean that wouldn't
really make too much sense i guess for a
2d game
but maybe our sprite is some some kind
of like arbitrary
shader that generates the actual sprite
itself right so it might be something
that's just
generated on the fly maybe it's a
particular texture maybe it's
you guys kind of get the point it could
be anything it could be really any
material
but at this point it's just simply a
color and i don't even think we can
assign a texture to it now
it'd be nice to assign a texture to it
and i think we will extend it to be like
that in the future
but for now i believe it's just this in
fact the way that we render sprites at
the moment
should mean that the actual color can be
set to white
and then we can have a texture that's by
default a one by one white texture
and that way it actually like doesn't
matter we could have both we could have
both the color and the texture
and then the color would tint the
texture if the texture is present
otherwise it would just obviously show
up like this because the texture is
white
so in other words we should actually be
able to
easily set a texture onto the sprite
component if we want to
anyway point is we just have a transform
component for these two because
that's all they have they have a
transform component a tag component
and then also a a sprite renderer
component which is what we're going to
add the ui for
today now i want to quickly mention that
um the tag component which is what we
actually saw was something that we need
to do well i'm very overexposed
um light shield myself
um the tag component ui is also
something we need to look at so
as far as i'm concerned that's basically
done i mean we've got this
tag component like obviously the labels
appear on the right side and that's
wrong and we'll fix that later in the
polishing ui stage
but for now this looks great and
obviously it's fully functional you can
see i can rename this
to rename rename this to like anything i
want and obviously it will update
so as far as i'm concerned tag component
is in fact done
we can look at the code for that but i'm
pretty sure it's fine so
we'll be mostly focusing on the sprite
renderer component so whenever you're
designing the ui for something like this
uh
the the easiest way to do this and in
fact the way that i'm
i usually do this is i simply look at
our components and i see okay what on
earth is in the sprite render a
component
at the moment literally just a color
right that's all it contains
now this should potentially contain a
texture as i mentioned
but more correctly it should probably
contain some kind of material from our
material library
maybe even a material instance right and
then
the way that this would kind of work is
you need to have some kind of
sprite compatible shader and material so
you could have a shader that just simply
draws a textured quad or something like
that
and then obviously a material is we
haven't talked about materials at all
really but a material
is a shader plus any kind of uniform
data so a shader plus data
um and so what you would have in this
case is potentially the shader being
like our texture shader
and then like an actual texture or an
actual color value like this
right so that's how it would work um and
the material obviously is capable of
holding both the shader and the data so
that would be all there and that'd be
fine
and we would just need to provide some
kind of ui for that which we could
pretty much automatically do because if
we query the shader and we find out hey
what uniforms do you have
available to us you know that you're
exposing into a material instance or a
material
we can automatically probably generate
some ui for that so we don't even have
to worry about this too much but we
could also have a custom tailored kind
of solution
for the sprite renderer component
specifically because we know that that's
something
that we more or less uh you know it's
it's not like it's infinite
possibilities
a sprite renderer is a sprite renderer
and in most cases you'll be either
rendering like a color
a colored sprite or some kind of texture
and that's kind of it anyway
that being said uh our job's pretty easy
here today um
we can probably talk about how to get a
texture into this
because at this point you guys kind of
get the point of how we add components
now
all we have to do the camera component
was pretty meaty right it was pretty
large
because we had this whole kind of block
here to write and obviously we had
different types of cameras as well
but this is a lot easier right um uh the
uh
you know if we copy the transform
component as an example um the sprite
render
component is a lot better so let's just
implement that so we have a sprite
renderer component
we'll use this projector's component
type id hash code just as this little
temporary id for im gui
we will type in sprite renderer
over here and then uh the transform
obviously needs to go away and we'll i
mean you know
realistically this is just going to be
i'm going color edit
uh now we'll use a color edit 4 of
course because i believe our sprite
renderer
so if we go to our components it has a
vector right so we also have alpha there
important you use this that way you can
manipulate
you can manipulate the alpha using the
i'm going as well um
i i never remember if i want color edit
or color picker
so um color edit functions have a little
colored preview square that can be left
clicked right
and a picker is the actual picker in
line so we want the edit because we want
to be able to just have a little square
that we click on to expand the actual
color picker
so that is good i just read that using
the kind of documentation in the
comments provided by i am gooey
so this is going to be the color
essentially
again very basic kind of baby steps at
the moment
and the color is going to be if we
basically do the same thing here
so we'll do sprites component sc or
sprite render component src
and then this will be a sprite renderer
component and that's what we'll retrieve
and then this is just going to be
src.color and of course we can just use
our classic glm value pointer to uh
to give us a pointer to that array of
four floats uh that's it i think
yeah it's pretty simple isn't it so you
saw how quick that was
i mean adding a new component to the ui
like really really fast now
this is still not something i would
label as ideal
because if you look at this for example
we're repeating this code
pretty much every time so for every
single
component we have this kind of same
pattern we've got does it
exist does it have it and then take the
type id of it
call it by its name and then the rest
goes here right
and then we have to have end and tree
pop as well
so what we'll do in the future is
something that we do in hazel dev which
is basically
we just make a function called uh and
we'll talk about that next time maybe or
the time
after we'll see we call it draw
component right it's a templated
function that just takes in the name of
the component
and then potentially what you actually
want to call it and then it also takes
in a lambda
where you can just add your component
specific ui code
and that way when we actually make the
i'm gui code a little bit more
complicated i think it probably makes
sense to do this in the polish ui stage
um that way when we actually make our
our uh ui component
our component ui more complicated and
like with the labels on the left side
and all this other extra imgui code that
we have to write
it's more standardized meaning that like
we don't have to we only put the
camera specific stuff here which in this
case would be
um you know the color edit for and like
you know retrieving this so in other
words in this case
this would actually go there and that is
exactly what our camera component ui
would look like
everything else is automated or kind of
automatically done
by this draw component function because
it's the same for each component
and we want it to be exactly the same
for each component because we want to be
consistent in styling
right so that's something that we'll do
in the future if you want a little bit
more of an exercise and some homework
perhaps to do for hazel try and do this
yourself you know based on what i've
kind of
shown you right here just convert the
component system
yourself so that you can basically write
some code that looks somewhat like this
if it looks even cleaner than
great right something like this so that
we can just you know draw the camera
component
draw the sprite renderer component etc
right and it's like super easy
and you can just do stuff like that and
add the specific ui here but everything
else is automatic and you can even have
a go at like making the labels be on the
left side
and all that um and if you do come up
with something that you think looks
really good in terms of ui styling then
just submit a pull request
or an or open an issue on the hazel
engine repository which is just
github.com
hazel link in the description um and
then yeah maybe
we'll adopt your style because i'm
obviously uh you know i want this to
look good
and if the community wants to help them
amazing okay
so anyway now that that's pretty much
done uh let's just hit f5
take a look at what this looks like okay
everything was cancelled apparently
sometimes visual studio can be just a
complete
ball of fun so in this case we actually
have to restart everything so let me
just close this
yeah i know sometimes sometimes visual
studio
is as i said a ball of fun
ball of fun the stream likes that by the
way you can't you can't see the the chat
on stream but stream likes it
shout out to the breaking hit randomly
let's hit f5 and now everything
magically works
so you know just visual studio things
that's all
okay so now that we've got this on
screen we should be able to click on the
square and look
magically we can see the color here it's
green here it's red here we know we have
a sprite renderer component it's
automatically expanded there's our
little color picker we can drag this
over and it displays everything here
now i'm interested in alpha so can we
reduce the alpha we can in fact
and for some reason i'm not actually
seeing the green square even though
we're reducing the alpha right
so if i reduce the alpha here that's
just not here at all and if i move it a
little bit
and the reason this is happening most
likely is because i think we've got
depth testing
enabled but also it's just based on the
render order so red square happens to be
most likely rendered first and at that
point it can't blend with anything
because there's just the clear color
inside the depth buffer inside the color
buffer
and then finally when the uh depth
buffer doesn't matter too much here but
when the green square gets rendered on
top of that it's opaque anyway so it
doesn't matter
on the green square if we did reduce the
alpha i'm pretty sure it would blend
with
uh the red square although i'm
completely wrong it seems so maybe
blending is just disabled or something
like that that's kind of weird isn't it
um and we've still got this this kind of
control over here so yeah it seems like
we just can't get these two to blend
most likely because blending is disabled
anyway this is not really what i wanted
to do this episode but
what what happened to gel blend that's
weird blending is disabled
but it can't be i'm pretty sure it's
enabled um
yeah we had uh gel enable and then
source alpha one minus source alpha
that's weird um
i guess it's possible they're at the
same depth when we're rendering we're
not gonna talk about 2d rendering
specifically today
yeah actually i think it's because
they're zed fighting or they're at the
same depth
um we're not going to talk about that
specifically today but
um just so you know usually when you
when you're rendering true 2d
things you just render them back to
front so stuff in the background goes
first and then you just
disable depth test because you don't
need it you just run it back to front
and then everything usually is okay
so that technically is what you would
probably do if you were actually truly
making a 2d game so that would look
something like when we actually draw the
quads and we go through um
uh although that wouldn't work with
a batch rendering situation because
obviously we draw
stuff kind of at once so it's a bit
weird so in that case
i think that we would need to probably
yeah let different layers work
differently as well here but um
if we just like the green square i think
we probably need to
just change the change the position here
um so you can see that now if we make
that position a little bit different for
a bash renderer
you can see that you get that kind of um
you get that kind of effect going here
because now it really is truly
um in front however if we had it if we
have them both at zero
they don't really work so that's kind of
what you would do if you were if you
were rendering everything in a bash
renderer
since everything kind of gets rendered
at once and there's no kind of
opportunity for blending
the same way as if you had everything as
a separate draw call anyway
um random information there obviously
but there we go we've got the ability to
change the color pretty cool
if we wanted to draw a texture we could
also set that up i'm not sure if i want
to add that stuff
uh now because of the whole material
situation but maybe we'll do that next
time we'll see
okay anyway um this is the uh
the square color thing that i want to
remove now so square color
so yeah we have this like if m square
entity and then we have the tag here
that's what said green square and then
this square color and you can just get
rid of all this
um and then we also had camera b didn't
we so another checkbox here as well we
don't really need any of this stuff
we have the ortho size i think like this
stuff is just
silly at the moment camera transform
that stuff obviously exists so we'll
clean up
this file a little bit and all this
stuff here we'll leave the settings just
basically
more or less being like the render stats
so maybe i will actually call this
render stats
um and then uh
and in fact i might call this renderer
2d stats
right um i mean we've already got this
here right
now i'll just call it stats there'll be
all sorts of stats here
um what was the other thing i wanted to
do
oh yeah this stupid clip space entity i
i need to go back through the episodes
and see how that came to be because it's
clearly just a camera
maybe it used to be something else man
whatever and i guess we should call this
camera a um
i probably didn't make the compile here
did i nope
uh so now that we've renamed the i'm gui
panel it has no idea where it's supposed
to be
so let's snap that back and make sure
that saves
um so yeah and camera ah that didn't
work either
why do we still have camera empty do
that let's try and recompile that maybe
um and then finally uh what did i want
to do what was the other thing oh yeah i
just didn't
didn't want them to be at the same place
but i guess that's fine let's just have
five
okay cool so there we go um
let's move uh so camera a camera b cool
we can enable camera b as the primary
if we want and you know disable camera a
from the primary all that stuff works
we should need to have that extra stuff
here we now have two squares as well
um and we can set them up in such a way
where they blend uh if we just reduce
the alpha and actually move this a bit
forward
so it's on top of that okay cool there
we go pretty cool
we now have the sprite renderer
component obviously i mean we added like
this one control here but hopefully um
you know some of the discussion was
helpful to you guys
who want to maybe send this a bit
further or for like educational purposes
and i think that next time we can
happily check that off because that's
currently done
uh we obviously still want to be able to
render textures and i'm i'm beginning to
think that
maybe it's worth us kind of revising our
shading and material system before we
dive into that since
effectively we'd be creating temporary
code anyway if we just started adding
like a
you know a file picker to like open a
brand new texture or something like that
and then render it here
i feel like maybe we should make a
materials panel and then talk about
materials and different shaders and
stuff like that let me know what you
guys think about that and if that would
interest you
maybe we'll even uh put that in a
different place although
i think we still should probably finish
this list and then maybe next up
before c and serialization we can maybe
start to work in a material system
because that way
we'll be able to just easily uh
construct things within hazel here
but then also have them be textured
quads not just you know
colored chords here because that that
can be a little bit boring
anyway that's it um did we check that
off
i think we did yeah sprite render
component ui is done
uh thank you guys for watching i hope
you enjoyed this episode of the game
engine series if you did please hit that
like button
if you're listening to this on twitch
then you can follow the stream or even
subscribe if you're feeling
particularly generous um don't forget
that you can uh help support the series
by going to patreon.com where you get
access to the hazel dev like the 3d
version of this engine like
and uh all of the stuff that exists
there like c sharp scripting and
this whole ui already done and uh you
can really use that to make some kind of
small games and
um you also get access to like live
streams that i've done in the past
as well specifically for that 3d version
of hazel as well if you're
if you are interested thank you all for
watching have a great rest of your day
or night or whatever it is
i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you